Assassin's Creed Valhalla's a Viking
setting is confirmed but that's not all
we know here are the important details
about the new game story characters and
launch platforms like PS 5 and series X
Valhalla is set in the 9th century at
the height of the Viking Age your clan
has been driven out of Norway leaving
them to seek shelter elsewhere the clan
is led by a boar who can be either male
or female much like how Odyssey let you
choose between Alexios or Cassandra in
fact Valhalla's modern-day storyline
with Laila picks up right after the
cliffhanger ending of odyssey's fate of
Atlantis DLC a VARs role in Valhalla is
somewhat similar to Edwards in Black
Flag like Edward a vork comes across the
assassin Templar conflict rather than
inherits it from birth as shown in the
trailer Valhalla's bird of choice is a
raven rather than the standard eagle the
assassins lean towards it makes sense
given the setting and Norse mythology
Odin uses his many Ravens to spy on his
enemies that might bring another recent
Norse adventure God of War to mind but
Ubisoft isn't worried about that
comparison we spoke to narrative
director Darby McDevitt about this and
he said it's Valhalla's grounded
historical experience that sets it apart
quote I think the urge is to always
immediately lead with the mythology
stuff but we really want you to feel
like you're living in the dark ages of
England that you're exploring the ruins
left behind 400 to 500 years earlier by
the Romans and the remnants of the
Britannic tribes before that and even
the Saxon pagans before they all
converted to Christianity that grounded
history can be seen in the game's
antagonists - the trailer shows King
Alfred of Wessex one of many leaders who
oppose the Viking forces but King Alfred
is just one villain he's not the game's
main bad guy McDevitt said Ubisoft wants
to save that reveal for later if this
info is enough to get you to pre-order
the game then you should know it has
four different editions in the works the
collector's edition does have a pretty
sweet-looking a horse statue you can get
all the pricing information on that
through GameSpot's pre-order guide as
for when Valhalla launches it's coming
to ps4 PS 5 Xbox one see
sex and PC via the epic game store this
holiday
[Music]